let's see if we can give ourselves an
intuitive understanding of the mean
value
theorem
and as we'll see if you once you parse
some of the mathematical lingo and
notation it's actually a quite intuitive
theorem
and so let's just think about some
function f
so let's say i have some function f and
we know a few things about this function
we know that it is continuous
continuous
over
continue us
the closed interval
between x equals a and x is equal to b
and so when we put these brackets here
that just means closed interval that
means we're including so i put a bracket
here that means we're including the
point a
and if i put the bracket on the right
hand side instead of a parenthesis that
means that we are including the point b
and continuous just means we don't have
any gaps or jumps in the function over
this closed interval
now let's also assume that it's
differentiable
it's differentiable
over the open interval
between a and b so now we're saying well
it's okay if it's not differentiable
right at a or if it's not differentiable
write it b and differentiable just means
that there's a defined derivative that
you can actually take the derivative at
those points
so it's differentiable over the open
interval between a and b so those are
the constraints we're going to put on
ourselves for the mean value theorem and
so let's just try to visualize this
thing
so
this is my function
that's the y-axis
and
this right over here is the x-axis
and i'm going to see x-axis and let me
draw my interval
so that's a
and then this is
b
right over here and so let's say our
function looks something like this let's
say look something
draw an arbitrary function
right over here let's say my function
looks something like that so this point
right over here the x value is a and the
y value is f of a
f of a
this point right over here
the x value is b
and the y value of course is f of b
f of b
f b
so all the mean value theorem tells us
is if we take the average rate of change
over the interval that at some point the
instantaneous rate of change at least at
some point in this open interval the
instantaneous change is going to be the
same as the average change now what does
that mean visually so let's calculate
the average change the average change
between point a and point b well that's
going to be the slope of the secant line
that's going to be the slope
of the secant line
so that's so this is the secant line so
think about its slope all the mean value
theorem tells us
is that at some point in this interval
this the instant slope of the tangent
line is going to be the same as the
slope of the secant line and we can see
just visually it looks like right over
here the slope of
the slope of the tangent line is it
looks like the same as the slope of the
secant line it also looks like the case
right over here the slope of the tangent
line is equal to the slope of the secant
line and it makes intuitive sense at
some point your instantaneous slope is
going to be the same as the average
slope
now how would we write that
mathematically
well let's let's calculate let's
calculate well
let's calculate the average slope over
this interval well the average slope of
the over this interval or the average
change the slope of the secant line is
going to be our change in y
our change in y right over here
over our change in x
over our change
our change in x
well what is our change in y our change
in y is f of b
minus f of a
minus
f of a and that's going to be over
that is going to be over our change in x
over b
minus
b minus a let me do that in that right
color so let's just remind ourselves
what's going on here so this right over
here this is the
graph of y is equal to f of x we're
saying that the slope of the secant line
or our average rate of change over the
interval from a to b
is our change in is our change in y
our change in y
that the greek letter delta is just
shorthand for change in y
over our change in x
over our change
in x which of course is equal to this
and the mean value theorem tells us that
there exists so if
if we know these two things about the
function
then
there exists
some
some x value in between a and b so in
the open interval between a and b there
exists some c
there exists some c and we could say
it's a member of the open interval
between a and b between a
and b or we could say some c such that a
is less than
such that a a is less than c which is
less than b
so some c in this interval so some c
some see in in between it where the
instantaneous rate of change at
at that x value is the same as the
average rate of change so there exists
some c in this open interval where the
average rate of change is equal to the
instantaneous rate of change
at that point that's all it's saying and
as we saw in this diagram right over
here this could be rc or this could be
our c
as well so nothing nothing really it
looks you know you say f is continuous
over a b differentiable over uh
over f is continuous over the closed
interval differentiable over the open
interval and you see all this notation
you're like what is that telling us all
it's saying is at some point in the
interval the instantaneous rate of
change is going to be the same as the
average rate of change over the whole
interval and the next video we'll try to
give you a kind of a real life example
about when when that makes sense